non-minimalists
how do we let go of long-term
commitments and obligations
especially the things we typically enjoy
but we're just
burnt out on so long-term
long-term commitments and obligations
things that we've committed to
right here i'll just give my pithy
answer and then maybe ben can expand
everything you've picked up
you can put down i think we don't
realize that all of a sudden we're
traveling up mount everest with
uh 150 pounds worth of gear on our back
and it's we picked it all up one ounce
at a time too
right and not realizing like oh man i've
got
so much and this weight can be literal
you can have a lot of stuff
but there can be all of these other
weights too the obligations and
commitments
that zoe's talking about here yes
uh anthony demelo in his book awareness
sums it up quite nicely
when he says that we should be able to
look at anything in life that we derive
pleasure from and
say to that object that item that person
that thing that activity
i derive pleasure from you but i am not
attached to you for my happiness i do
not depend upon you
for my happiness if there is anything in
your life that you can't say that
to without feeling a little pit in your
stomach and a little bit of resistance
to saying that then that is something
that has become
an unhealthy attachment or a pleasure
that you're actually relying upon
for your happiness so i would read
anthony demelo's book awareness very
quick read
simple to get through but it really
teaches you how to release a lot of
those attachments how to release a lot
of those pleasures and
i've found that that for me in terms of
cleaning up the clutter
that a big part of it a big part of that
clutter
is related to what another author
napoleon hill
dictates in his book outwitting the
devil outwitting the devil describes
this so-called hypnotic trance
right these rituals these habits these
routines that we set up for ourselves
that we become very addicted to
throughout the day you know we have this
dopaminergic response to
you know i've got my stretch routine on
fitness you know i got my stretch
routine i got my breath routine i got
this workout i got that workout oh i
just found out about the saunas now i
gotta do the sauna and oh somebody's
talking about cold thermogenesis so i
need to figure out how to throw that in
the room
by the end of the day there's all these
things to do
right but you can get drawn into it as
just like this hypnotic trance of
rituals and routines
and habits and you need to be able to
step back and identify those things that
you're just doing because they've become
a habit that you feel like you have to
do versus those things that are actually
necessary and crucial
for you to feel really fulfilled at the
end of the day and you'd be surprised at
how few things there are
that are actually truly necessary versus
those things that become
mildly addictive habits yeah you know
this question makes me think about what
you were
talking about earlier with uh examining
our purpose
and being willing to change that i think
the same thing goes with our commitments
maybe you know on a yearly basis you
look down and look at all your
commitments
and ask yourself which ones are worth
keeping and which ones
might have to go what you might have to
change my pithy answer is this a
meaningful life overflows with joy
not commitments so when i think about
that
when i was reading this question i also
thought about how a commitment
should ultimately lead you to something
joyful
you know if uh i know there are certain
commitments in life that you know we've
got to go to work and pay the bills
but ultimately that is leading to
something joyful but if you've committed
to something
that is uh completely non-joyful
um i give you permission to let it go so
you